with the best and the worst animated
moments of the resurrection of a park in
the books it's finally time to decide
whether or not it's worth watching over
the movie both had some great aspects
and not so stellar parts and seeing how
they both cover roughly the same part of
the Dragon Ball timeline I feel now is
the time to pit them against each other
in a battle for the respect of the
Dragon Ball community our contestants
will compete in five rounds each round
represents an area integral to these two
pieces of Dragonball media it's time to
decide once and for all which one should
be skipped all together and which one
should be our gospel this is animated
movie Dragon Ball super versus
resurrection F before I begin have you
watched 10 hours worth of this arc and
after producing 20 minutes worth of
detailed analysis concerning it in my
last two videos there is nothing more
gag-inducing than the thought of having
to dive straight back into episode 15 to
see Vegeta screaming oh what death the
cheating you're standing at a rock
screaming didn't see that word coming
bro but I never say that and this video
is bigger than me okay here we go
[Music]
Dragon Ball fans like the pretty
pictures they do heck I love them it's
easily one of the most interesting
topics of discussion within the Dragon
Ball community who are these faceless
phantoms that orchestrate these moving
pencil scratches it's one of the reasons
I made this channel in the first place
there does however seem to be a metric
crap ton of misinformation out there if
my comments section is anything to go by
comments like why can't they make it
like one punch man or attack and Titan
and really I think this is due to the
animation process being largely and
unknown to the vast majority of the
fanbase it isn't the subject hot in our
schools or a topic tackled in many
movies and over the last couple of
months I have been trying to shine a
light on this shadowy subject as best I
can
this isn't the video for this discussion
but I might make one in the future who
knows now the main thing to take away
from this is that Dragon Ball super
isn't supposed to be better than
resurrection event at least from a
visual perspective the animators
directors and producers knew this Dragon
Ball super soul purpose for existing is
to increase merchandise sales that is
where Dragon Ball has always made its
money now with that said with the series
creator a curatorial of bad-mouthing the
show's animation quality I am not about
to question the great
but I know what you're thinking if the
show is for merch purposes exclusively
then why is he putting down super well
you see there is a threshold when you
are making a weekly anime you have to
juggle a few balls schedule quality and
the public now for the sake of this not
being a 20-minute round discussing
animation let's just say that for the
release of Dragon Ball super back in
2015
things in the scheduling department
didn't exactly go the way they wanted
and as a result the quality slipped
public then swelled into a frenzy the
likes of which would make Goku ko kayo
nope resurrection of F on the other hand
was gorgeous looking and this was
largely due to the schedule of the movie
as well as the budget allotted by tobe
for the production this was to be a
visual extravaganza it wasn't just for
selling toys though that was a goal -
but this was to get the franchise off of
its laurels for another run or to be
resurrected if you will for those of you
who were around when this act was in its
run late last year you remember that the
number one thing discussed amongst fans
was what are they doing this again why
can't they just give us some new stuff
and guess what I bet my life that the
animators were thinking the exact same
thing
imagine having already worked on a
visually demanding movie like
resurrection F and then being faced with
one more year to work on the exact same
story only with less time and pay of
course they'll try their best but the
scenario doesn't exactly breathe passion
now does it maybe that's why my favorite
parts of this arc were from the scenes
that didn't make it into the movie they
were probably toast to make as well
regardless nothing in the series quite
stands up to the movies aesthetics point
goes to the movie
considering Frieza is the movie's title
character I thought only fitting that I
give him his own category B for beat
both the anime and the movie hit all the
key plot points revived Frieza the
rejuvenation tank freezes plan Frieza
come sir but how this is executed is at
least a little different
freezes planted both the anime and the
movie is to train for a period of time
to achieve a new level of strength what
the anime did differently to the movie
however was give us a glimpse at the
horror that was freezes training Tajima
will be beaten and brutalized by Frieza
at the end of each day toggle I would
have to drag his body into the
rejuvenation tank before he would
continue training the next day forget
Deadpool who was in a chamber for a few
days
Tajima was victimized and brought to the
brink of debt every single day for four
damn months it really brings an aura of
terror to Frieza helps the audience see
him as a true maniac resurrection F the
movie expected fans to know all the
backstory going it did nothing for the
casual viewer the anime gave just enough
character exposition as well as
interesting interactions for the
audience to enjoy no matter what level
of fan they were now in saying that I
realized Frieza is an established
character within the Dragon Ball mythos
and you will most certainly find many
fans watching these scenes thinking I
already know this however these scenes
aren't for them it's for the thousands
of children who might be new to the
series and don't know who Friesen is but
as I said his character is already fully
fleshed out and while I think the added
scenes of Frieza brutalizing toggler
might be fun they are not as important
as beerus is in the battle of gods movie
which is why I will only award the anime
half a point half points don't get used
to it just this once off this one here
is actually quite interesting I think as
it should be it concerns the two most
prevalent characters in the entire
series the Prince of all Saiyans Vegeta
and our main protagonist Goku both
portrayals are actually quite great I
must say but an extra dimension was
added to this equation that I feel is
worth considering but I'm getting ahead
of myself here so let's start from the
beginning the movie has us begin with
these two as they are training with
weeks the most important thing to take
from this is that this exact scene is
done in the anime - on episode 19 it
hits all the same notes as this scene
does in the movie it even looks great
the anime however begins on episode 15
as it should with Vegeta Vegeta on the
rock enraged that Goku has slipped
further and further ahead of him skip
forward and we sugreeva train vegeta on
his own the anime doesn't start covering
what the movie did until episode 19 this
means that the anime has the added
advantage of covering the training Goku
and Vegeta had prior to this scene from
the movie ever since I was a kid I
wanted to see the kind of training that
Vegeta and Goku would undergo together
if the occasion arose why because it
would be awesome and episode 19 of the
anime was awesome it was funny and it
was awesome for awesome
Dragon Ball really went back to its
roots with this one and ultimately this
became my favorite episode of the arc
the movie didn't think to include such
scenes and in my opinion suffers because
of it in the movie
Super Saiyan blue does
feel earned it just sort of feels like
something added on for the sake of
having a transformation in a movie
now you might still believe that Super
Saiyan blue is forced in the anime also
but even you guys must admit that it
felt so much more organic when we saw
what these guys went through to achieve
that power it made more sense in the
movie there is so little Vegeta it's
almost sickly now in saying that the
movies fight is infinitely better and to
even compare the two is an insult to the
movie but we are not discussing which
had the best fight here we are
discussing the characters and the
movie's portrayal of the cheetah is
lacking in my opinion having only about
25 lions by the time he begins his fight
with freezer the cheetah is seriously
lacking in dialogue of any kind the
anime on the other hand gives Vegeta
much much more exposure and is better
off because of it and yes I know the
animation softs but if you are looking
at this from a purely character driven
point of view the anime just gives us
much more bang for our buck and these
aren't even the most important
differences nope that comes a little
later and it's probably the most
important piece of information revealed
about Goku and Vegeta in both the anime
or the movie but I'm gonna park that for
now and discuss it in a later round for
now it's close but if I'm being honest
the anime did both Goku and Vegeta much
better point goes to the anime ladies
and gentlemen I present to you the most
one-sided category in this entire video
the movie is gorgeous looking we have
discussed that in the animation section
already but when it comes to fight
choreography the movie has it one easily
be it Bruce Lee's one-inch punch the
base form Goku exchange with Frieza
the fights beginning Goku's kamehameha
vs freezes death ball there are so many
great moments to this fight that are
both captivating and interesting the
animate on the other hand looked like a
bunch of wooden puppets dancing across
our screen I've ranted on this before
but the animes battle had so many blast
sequences I don't care if I'll ever see
one again the animes version of this
fight is easily the worst battle in all
of Dragon Ball noting visually
interesting happens at all and when it's
compared to the movies version of the
same fight it's like comparing Raddatz
to whis it shouldn't even be in the same
conversation because the latter is so
far beyond anything the former is bad
animation I can excuse but the lack of
imagination that went into this fight is
almost insulting point goes to the movie
hands down
remember when I said that the points I
made about Goku and Vegeta weren't even
the most important ones well the reason
I didn't include that in the Goku and
Vegeta category was due to with
primarily concerning the story
the main story of this movie slash arc
is that of Goku and Vegeta that's right
it's not Freeza Freeza might play a
pivotal role in all of this but at the
end of the day he's just a catalyst for
Goku and Vegeta's story and the entire
story stems from that brief dialogue
Reis has with both Goku and Vegeta
embarrasses world in short he explains
to Vegeta the reason why he's Goku
lesser telling him that while he is a
gifted fighter his nerves are wound just
too tight and he needs to rest when the
opportunity presents itself so that he
can react without thinking he then
explains that Goku has the opposite
problem letting his guard down too
frequently and being far too
overconfident this comes into play later
in the story from both for this example
I will be using the moment Goku and
Vegeta land on the battlefield up until
the end of the movie or arc as a time
frame to illustrate my points this ends
up being the last 40 minutes of the
movie and the last 4 episodes of the arc
but what's the difference you might be
asking well in short the movie is very
Goku centric and the anime while
developing Goku also develops vegeta
equally those of you that have seen the
movie might recognize this scene as the
only one that is significant to what we
sworn them about and that's because
Vegeta directly references it when
speaking with Goku as he's lying there
on the floor defeated in the anime
however there are many more instances
that echo Lisa's words as Goku and
Vegeta touched down on the battlefield
Tajima sorbet freezes are me and Frieza
himself stand before them three of these
four pieces will come into play and this
is how it plays out it begins when the
cheetah doesn't take any chances and
destroys hakama from the get-go playing
on the Goku being too unguarded and
overconfident captain ginyu in Tagum his
body would have almost certainly wreaked
havoc on the Z warriors Vegeta was
correct to eliminate him from the
equation but I don't think Goku was
capable of making such a quick decision
when Goku ultimately begins fighting
with freezer again playing into his
overconfidence go who doesn't go all out
against Frieza right away however when
Goku fights Frieza at full power his
fighting potential isn't limited by his
nerves being wound too tightly
if a cheetah were in this scenario he
may have become frustrated and
that he is struggling against Frieza
remember when he was fighting against
Suisse earlier his temper is an issue
the cheetah is the one that brings to go
whose attention that Frieza is weakening
proving that Vegeta is in fact a gifted
fighter and that Goku is again to
unobservant now comes apart that
everyone made the connection with sorbet
fires the ray gun through goku's chest
this one specifically makes much more
sense in the anime since Goku is in his
base form when it happened in the movie
he is in Super Saiyan blue which makes
no sense at all this again preys on the
idea that Goku is too unguarded and
trusting when in combat this is
absolutely not something that would have
befallen Vegeta and this final one plays
- the last thing we spoke about being
able to move without thinking to
anticipate the opponent's move without
processing thought this final scene
where Vegeta stands above Fraser
I think hits the nail on the head
neither Goku nor vegeta were able to
stop Frieza from blowing up fear this is
where I feel we use this as a training
exercise we quickly reduce time and go
who does not hesitate to vaporize
freezer from the face of the earth the
anime performs this story much much
better than the movie does it has a
clear narrative throughout and finishes
on a conclusion that makes sense with
the story the anime also had the benefit
of telling the story of how Vegeta came
to train with Wiese in the first place
it also didn't make stupid mistakes like
this for me it's clear that if anyone
looks at this objectively from a story
perspective the anime is the clear
winner here point goes to the anime now
with all the points cut it off the anime
wins by half a point which I have to say
isn't very satisfying and to be quite
honest with a battle as terrible as the
anime has it's really hard to justify
watching it over the movie which is why
I have come up with a compromise I have
created an option seat or should I say
Ajay has created an option safe I have
sung this man's praises before but at
anime AG on Twitter has created a
fan-made version of the resurrection of
f' movie that includes some of my
favorite scenes from the anime
altogether it's much better than both
the anime and the movie because it takes
the best parts of both we get to see
much more of ochita struggle in training
with Goku but we also see the kick-ass
fight sequences from the movie it's a
win-win it's a really kind gesture and
it just goes to show how creative and
hardworking some members of the anime
community can be I'll leave a link to
anime a J's Twitter and you can download
the fan made version there trust me guys
it's well worth the viewing I've
totally not mark and this is being
Dragon Ball super versus resurrection F
thank you so much for watching